I'm delighted interest who introduces
next gentleman he's a good friend he's a
remarkable man mr. George Burns 83 years
old George is a bachelor and always
keeps company with a very young lovely
companion George of course is quite
concerned about the outcome of the
Marvin decision ah I would think they'd
hate to think of some young lady ending
up with half of George's hot barley soup
and with George as a remarkable young
lady who recently saw Tatum O'Neal at a
party and said when I'm her age I hope I
look that good to present the word for
outstanding actress in a supporting role
George Burns and Brooke Shields
Maggie oh love just because I happen to
be up here with this lovely young lady I
don't want you to think she's my date
that's true I'm not his date no it's
just that we've made a movie together
it's called just you and me kid
and you know how the studio's like to
spread those stories about stars being
romantically involved with sells tickets
Jed that we were romantically involved
I'd sell tickets
let's get to the ladies who have made
their mark this year by their
exceptional performances in five
exceptional movies the nominees for
outstanding performance by an actress in
a supporting role are Dyan Cannon and
heaven can wait
okay Penelope Milford and coming home
Maggie Smith and California sweet
Maureen Stapleton and interior
Meryl Streep in The Deer Hunter
and the winner is no no no you finish it
have fun you do the whole thing
the winner is maggie smith in california
I just I just really can't believe it uh
I'm very very honored and very grateful
I would like to thank Neil Simon I would
like to thank her by Ross and I would
very much like Michael came to be here
because believing me he was the most
supporting actor ever in the world and
it really should go right down the
middle thank you very much indeed